I'm all the boys I've known enough know
until I first met you all with smoke are
you recording
hi I'm so additionnal there's something
outside I don't know what it is but it's
kind of scary
um the book I'm reading right now I am
reading a little book called we little
garden gnome it's just really it's
really informative and I just really
like to read it and if I'm you know at
the DMV or some place that I need to
wait a while I just whip it out and and
there it is it's it's a journey
I love reading especially little books
they just know how to make me happy
one thing I wish we still had today
that's old-fashioned is I miss the old
fashioned funds um the ones that have a
little spinning noise mmm but that
that's my favorite I need to ghost
number two
ah my favorite song right now you want
me to sing it for you
okay um days go by yeah
Family Matters I love that song on my
free time I like to make clay sculpture
heads when I'm in an audition or a
meeting I just kind of when I get
nervous
I just have him talk and say hmm don't
match me sure and I feel better so I
take our class on my free time and I
don't like the big painter's palette
that they give me so I bring in my own
it's very petite and cute hmm and the
little paintbrush here's a little piggy
and a llama and a dinosaur and a flower
this is like a whole little movie right
here maybe the pig had a hard day
because people were making fun of how
pink he was and then this little guy he
is a psychiatrist and said no you have
to just be thankful for what color you
are okay I guess I'll just go and here
have a flower
I made my own movie
oh you know as an actress
um I have a wide range of emotions
I can play scared John don't go in there
I think there is a killer in there
he killed my dog yeah or I can play
happy - I'm so happy that your tooth
fell out finally did you get a quarter
for that mm-hmm
yeah I one time once I got like $20 or I
can play angry I'm so mad at you because
you didn't take out the trash I come
home and the trash is filled with candy
canes but couldn't you at least finish
them or give them to a little mouse or
something see I have a wide range of
emotions well I guess that's all for me
for today thank you so much for
interview and hanging out with me so
I'll see you around okay hmm fine
[Music]
hold on I'm just figuring this song out
okay
[Music]